mais ben voila je crois qu'avec tout ça
julie va pouvoir faire une soupe
extraordinaire bonjour quand toi à nos
jours casimir tiens qu'est ce que c'est
ça eh bien ce sont des légumes bar géant
rares des légumes labatut aviator avec
tout ce que j'ai apporté
julie va nous faire une soupe de légumes
formidable on va se régaler rien que de
voir des légumes
j'ai déjà ma locaux à d'ailleurs je suis
sûr que les enfants n'aiment pas ça non
plus oh bah moi je suis bien sûr du
contraire
oui bien on va leur demander un cd
heureux les enfants venez voir on est
allé voir regarder des légumes
ça ne vous donne pas mal au coeur avoue
non tu vois quasiment aucun des enfants
n'a mal au coeur et d'ailleurs je suis
certain qu'ils aiment beaucoup les
légumes bah moi je préfère m'en aller eh
ben c'est ça à tout à l'heure
casimir et nous pendant ce temps là on
va faire un jeu vous allez me dire quels
sont les légumes dont la partie qu'on
mange se trouve dans la terre d'accord
on y va voilà le premier
qu'est ce que c'est que ça ça c'est du
maïs ça se trouve dans la terre ou à
l'extérieur
vous avez déjà vu des champs de maïs mme
ces magnifiques 1 quelle hauteur ça à
peu près ah oui ça monte bien de mettre
ces magnifiques
bon qu'est ce que c'est que ça ça c'est
une courgette alors ça se trouve dans la
terre
dans la terre ou à l'heure de la terre
hors de la terre très bien salade c'est
très très bon les courgettes
ça c'est un radis noir il est long suis
l'un alors ça se trouve dans la terre
dans la terre on mange tous ont les plus
longs on retire le noir on mange avec du
sel du pain et du beurre c'est succulent
et ça qu'est ce que c'est tombé à eric
au vert ça pousse dedans hors de la
terre et vous avez vous avez vu comment
s'est jamais sa peau christophe on met
des bâtons planté dans la terre et
s'enroule autour des tuteurs ça monte
très très très très haut d'ailleurs 2,3
m voilà les ricoh vers ça ça c'est des
pommes de terre évidemment alors les
pommes de terre
ça pousse dans la terre vous les mangez
comment les pommes de terre on peut les
manger chaud décollé manger froides
on peut y manger en purée en salade on
les mange de toutes les façons possibles
et imaginables
ah c'est pas de l'ice et des années ont
alors les oignons c'est dans la terre
dans la terre
et quand on les épluche que ça fait les
oignons
tu connais des trucs pour éviter de
pleurer en épluchant les oignons y en a
beaucoup y en a qui font couler l'eau y
en a qui les met dans un sac en matière
plastique va ya il ya beaucoup de
procéder qu'est-ce qu'on va prendre la
tête tiens ça ça sondés n'avaient alors
7 pouces de dents dans la terre on les
met dans le pot-au-feu jamais le
pot-au-feu viennent pas le pot-au-feu
marque
c'est pourtant ce qu'ils ont et comme
casimir toi ça qu'est ce que c'est
carottes alors dans les terres c'est
faut dire efforts pour les arracher
d'ailleurs ça sent donc c'est du céleri
l'attention et c'est pas du thriller
céleri-rave que les céleris raves et une
grosse boule au bout alors ça ce qu'on
enchaîne dans la terre ou à l'extérieur
de la terre aux bonnes affaires et dans
le céleri rave on mange la boule et là
on mange les branches
retrouvez un petit morceau c'est très
très bon cru comme ça sont des braves
sont des betteraves alors de dents dans
la tête dans la terre en salade c'est
très très bon salade
alors tout le monde est d'accord oui
il nous reste comme ça sont des poireaux
est alors temps de terre on a exactement
voilà ça fait un peu près comme ça on le
coupe et tout le reste on peut le manger
et ben voila je crois qu'on a tous passé
en revue as tu as raison j'avais oublié
saisi les tomates et ça pousse dedans ou
l'extérieur
de quelle façon sur les tuteurs sur des
tuteurs et on les mange évidemment quand
elles sont rouges
et bien voilà les ensembles je crois
qu'avec tout ça on va pouvoir faire une
formidable soupe de légumes et bien
bravo
et chez vous vous aviez tout trouvé
c'est sûr parfait qui vient nous
maintenant on va faire une partie de la
meilleure êtes d'accord
dans le joli tout et légumes sont là sur
la table
allez venez on y va qui un foulard ben
je vais jamais avoir le temps de
ramasser tout ça puis d'ailleurs je sais
pas où ranger la moitié de mes affaires
moi j'ai pas assez plat car trop
d'affaires mais je sais que je peux pas
m'en sortir comme ça moi faut il est bon
lui c'est pas possible tu as tu as des
problèmes je suis dit oh oui quasiment j
j'ai beaucoup trop de choses à faire je
ne sais pas comment je vais m'en sortir
je sais pas je peux t'aider
tu veux bien mais débordé bien
volontiers à des coutumes amoureuses un
gros service bon ben je pourrais être
fier de moi après oui c'est clair je
vais m en pierre de moi j'arrête rapière
de noizay
casimir pour être fiers de toi après
m'avoir rendu le service à bord mais
qu'est ce que c'est bon bah tu vas
prendre ce palier tu vas aller me
ramasser tous les légumes qui sont sur
la table et tu me les rapportent les
coins les légumes là bas sur la table tu
les vois
mais ce sont des légumes ah oui c'est
simple tu les prends tu les ramasse
tumeur bas mais j'ai encore des légumes
je ne supporte pas de voir des légumes
bon bon bah si tu veux pas me faire
juste en plus les si je vais bientôt
rendre service mais dès que je vois des
légumes
je suis malade j'ai mal au coeur thomas
est certes toi ton imagination imagine
c'est pas moi que chaque légume est un
morceau du plus délicieux des
gloubiboulga je vais y arriver avec mon
imagination tu crois en suis certain
bon ben je vais essayer allez va être
bon bon alors je vais imaginer que ces
légumes sont de gloubiboulga voilà voilà
ça c'est un joli morceau de gloubiboulga
ans quel bon goût bulgare bien eu un
autre morceau de gloubiboulga voilà on y
l'epo un très beau morceau de
gloubiboulga attention voilà l bon
gloubiboulga voilà un autre morceau de
délicieux globules gars
délicieux encore un dernier morceau
voilà quel délicieux gloubiboulga julie
oui alors sa mère s'est formidablement
ton idée tu sais j'ai imaginé que chacun
des légumes était un morceau de
gloubiboulga et alors qui les a mis dans
le panier et non je les ai tous mangé je
n'ai pas pu résister un aussi délicieux
gloubiboulga ce soir on comptera en
anglais dans bonjour c'est à mme joly au
hive etc